the legacy of all who came before you  it is all a part of who you  i'm are change the course of history  but tonight  marvel's new avenger  arise  change  let's go  oh  come on  marvel shang-chi ready pg-13 be the  first to experience it in theaters  tonight  [Music]  those who came before us  who made us who we are today  everything you need is already inside of  you  there's no going back  it's time to show the world who i really  am  hell yeah  the marvel studio shanghai greedy pg-13  two weeks ago you were parking cars and  you're now saving the world yeah  in theaters this friday  you are a product  of all who came before you  in five days  [Music]  i've lived in the shadows  [Applause]  but now  it's time to show them  who i really am  i'm  ready  marvel seanchi ready pg-13 in theaters  this friday  you